نشره صحيفه تونيور تايمز الامريكيه تحليلا
قالت انه يكشف عن تطوير ايران سلاحها
الجوي واستعدادات لتسلمها المقاتل الروسيه
سوخوي 35 وقالت الصحيفه انها اعتمدت في
تحليلها على صور ومقطع فيديو وصور اقمار
صناعيه اظهرت احداها وفق الصحيفه ان
نموذجا بالحجم الطبيعي لطائر الروسيه
المقاتله بالاضافه الى رسومات ظهرت في
مقطع فيديو نشرته القوات المسلحه
الايرانيه لقاعده جويه جديده تحت الارض
حيث تشبه رسومات الطائرات تصميم طائرات
سووي 35 ونشرت صحيفه الامريكيه صور اقمار
صناعيه قالت انها لقاعده جويه في منطقه
جبليه في مقاطعه هرمز جان جنوبيه ايران
وكان الجيش الايراني قد كشف في السبع من
الشهر الجاري النقاب عن اول قاعده عسكريه
جويه تحت الارض والمسمات عقاب 44
ويحسب وبحسب المعلومات التي اوردها الجيش
الايراني فان القاعده المحفوره في اعماق
الجبال قادره على تخزين وتشغيل انواع
مختلفه من الطائرات المقاتله والقاذفات
والمسيرات واظهر مقطع فيديو نشرته قناه
ايرانيه محليه زياره قام كل من رئيس اركان
القوات المسلحه الايرانيه لواء محمد باقري
والقائد العام للجيش الايراني اللواء عبد
الرحيم موسوي للقاعده التي تحتوي ايضا
حظائر للطائرات الحربيه ومركزا للاصلاح
والصيانه وخزانات الوقود اضافه الى منطقه
انذار ومركز قياده